[Music]
colt is in montgomery alabama hi colt
how are you
i'm doing well dave thank you how are
you better than i deserve what's up
well first i'll start out i'm absolutely
emotionally mentally
in almost every way fashion exhausted
um financially i read your book in 2018
um when i was on my last military
deployment i'm actually active military
i've been in 10 years now thank you
that's mine
thank you i appreciate it
so read your book got motivated uh
started following your steps paid off
almost 40 000 dollars in debt
in just the first nine months of being
on your plan
then in 2019 i thought well i'm in a
better position i'm going to buy a
fixer-upper house i can do all the work
myself from blue-collar uh old farm boy
but i could take care of it well four
months later military dropped me orders
and i'm stuck with this house and i'm
like i can't really rent it out in the
status
so i made the dumb decision and panicked
and
put a whole lot of work into the house
on credit cards
and the last two years i've just been
treading water the tenants that i had in
it for two years
trashed it so all the work i put into it
pretty much was just undone
and then i had
thought really passively last summer
about selling it because the market's
hot
but then i thought no i'm still not
ready to part with it's an investment
i'll get a roommate from that's a best
friend from another state move him and
he was happy to move in and then we
walked in the door and went oh my gosh
this house
so
i'm sorry what's wrong with the house
they
were shown without a shower curtain so
the deal this week was is the wall and
the bathroom
buckled inward so i spent two weeks of
pto or leave i completely gutted and
raided the bathroom
uh every blind in the house was gone uh
just to filth
um
okay so then you panicked and you've
been on credit cards and you built it
back right
so what kind of condition is it in today
it's in a position where
it's it still needs paint um
kitchen's still a mess
but i mean it's livable
but
what are you doing
on it
uh 140.
and how much credit card debt did you
run up
uh 35 000 what would it sell for today
as it sits
talked to a realtor the other day she
said probably around 2 30
sell it
you would tell it there was nothing in
your conversation with me that sounded
fun so far you suck at this real estate
thing
[Laughter]
everything you've touched has turned to
poop on this man
yes get rid of it there's nothing here
fun i've
yeah i've been working in addition to
school
you breathed better
i know when i said sell it you went
thank god
hey and dude listen i
you and i could probably talk for an
hour um you and me and dave talk for an
hour
you've got other stuff in your life
going on don't you
yes way too much and you're running 10
years
on deployment return and deployment
return
and i hear
your voice is crackling you're fried is
that right
yep you have to be after last week
you've got to get some margin yeah get
some stuff off your plate
even if that means go live on base go
wrench yeah fire yourself from anything
you can to make your life simpler
i i really needed to hear that because
that's what i told myself when i was
driving home i said i've got to make my
life more simple
calm like almost boring you need some
boredom go talk to a counselor yeah go
pick up take up fishing
go you got to find some people go hang
out with some people that aren't in the
middle of enough take
i was gonna say golf and then i thought
i love him he loves our country so i
don't encourage golf um but hey look you
got to get some friends you got you have
to
your life has been living you for a
decade
and it's been one of service and one of
a lot of trauma and a lot of exhaustion
and this real estate thing's just one
more chapter yeah
where it's riding you you're not riding
it
so i'm not telling you you get a
military just keep doing what you're
doing but you got to create a life like
okay now i got to crest this wave kind
of like like dave is a great ski
instructor and when you first start
skiing and you're sitting in the water
and you come out and it's just blasting
you in the face eventually you can stand
up and you crest and you get on top of
that thing boats still go on the same
speed everything's still going the same
except you're on top of it that's what
we're talking about and that talks about
that's you backing up and deciding i'm
gonna do some things in my life
differently so i can be well what else
can you fire yourself from
well the second other job that i picked
up on the side that i'm exhausted
washing campers up in the hot alabama
sun to try to bring in some extra cash
you don't need extra cash we just got
rid of the house and put some money in
your pocket you're debt free
yeah that would be great
move on base get a one bedroom apartment
just control alt delete man
go to the gym laugh right go play god
don't play golf but whatever
right get some joy in your life man
you've worked too hard and you've given
too much of yourself to continue to run
like this go to the range and drop a
thousand rounds downrange that's that's
stressful
that's stress relieving okay and the
government will pay for it
the only other question i have though is
just
my roommate just moved down best friend
moved down just in february
i'm still trying to figure out how i
hand him a little bit of a check when
his house sells hand him a little bit of
a check
give him five grand go get him no give
him if you gave him a thousand dollars
and said i'm sorry i gotta get out of
this this is killing me
the thousand dollars is just to say i'm
sorry what would he say okay
he would was good at friends as we are i
think he would be perfectly fine with
that but it's still just the emotion
like i feel like i failed him you know
there's that that
that's how i feel about it also so
there's that that part of it well it's
why you're serving the military you're a
man of honor
so you're going to always have those
feelings about things and they're always
going to be about 2x what reality is
yeah yeah you did fail him but it ain't
near as big as it feels like inside of
you
in other words no big deal okay
if his life was all hooked up he
wouldn't have come
[Laughter]
right it didn't like you disjointed some
guy from his medical degree
he didn't have nothing to do anyway
that's why he lives in your house
so yeah i mean he it's okay he's gonna
be all right
um yeah give him a thousand bucks to say
thank you or i'm sorry or whatever you
want to call it and call that honor and
it is honor and um
help him some other way if you can
without signing up for some extra job
quit washing campers
go put a thousand rounds downrange get
yourself in a simplified life boring
life
and i'm gonna send you a copy of john's
book own your past to change your future
you need to read this book hold on
you're gonna love it you're gonna go oh
there i am
this is the ramsey show